excuse me he gets a minute all new film
project possibly that's nothing better
so the whole point of this episode is to
spread kindness and I feel like guys
don't call them that guys that so I'm
trying to challenge men to compliment
another man so what would happen is you
would get in the shot and I find another
guy it's a little out there I know would
you be down yeah I got you I'm doing all
right sir yeah Charlotte yeah sure sure
not a problem the hooker just give me a
second
I'm just gonna recruit another guy might
take a couple minutes okay is this the
person so do I like walk up to Wilbur
does he know I'm gonna come to rent it
that's great
hello stranger are you doing stranger
how you doing
what's your name I'm Erik I'm charlie
how's it going good Vinnie Danny Bob I'm
Bob how you doing ther
sale all right nice to meet you Sandra
my name is Jaime what's your name okay
my name is Luis I'm from Mexico Wow
where you from I'm from the United
Kingdom oh hey I wasn't expecting that
because I'm like like Tom Holland but I
look like Tom Holland no Tom Hollands
English is me how pretty is maybe maybe
I'm also a random stranger okay I'm Chad
Chad yeah Chad I'm Josh
I'm Ryan good to meet you dude what's
your name Herbert Herbert Fred nice to
meet you oh so you just go at it
well where you from I'm from Germany
from Germany what looks also give it a
really exciting story behind you I'm not
sure if there's an exciting story well
I'm a really lame person from Germany
I'm sure you're very exciting and
everything but uh you look very fit and
healthy I try it yeah yeah I think I
could be fitter Oh No
you're very beautiful you're a beautiful
man yeah you're also very handsome thank
you thank you sure thank you you know
I've gotta go searching and you'll find
whatever you need eventually but yeah
what do you do for what what's your job
I work at a high school oh really oh I'm
still in high school really yeah what do
you do in high school athletic director
oh really
what's uh some advice you forgive me for
high school enjoy the process see four
years want to find your life well just
by talking to you I feel you're a very
amazing how going person and be an
amazing teacher yeah I love your accent
it's very nice I think it's good very
like it everyone we spend of MU you said
that
ah it's pretty hot in here
so that's your friend that's her friend
we were to college together you know
it's nice
you have a cool vibe yeah yeah yeah
excuse me
hey no sir Kevin all right I just I said
I really enjoyed your shirt it's really
nice um saw her from afar what you know
it's really nice
yeah for the figure yeah so I just
wanted to tell you that your dreams are
Bali okay so great so far project I like
your hat nice I like the texture oh
sweet yeah that's awesome yeah
that's awesome I do want to let you know
I love your shirt where did you buy from
about it Spencer's oh must be awesome I
like your shirt
maybe you nice got some nice arms you
work out um here and there maybe not as
much as I'd like to but you know great
so you have family around um no no
good-looking guys so you should you know
think about enjoying these people so you
can establish a family like I've done
thank you yeah not opposed to it alright
alright
how long have you and your wife feeling
good um 11 almost 12 years
okay thank you thank you well hey enjoy
your stay in the park and keep looking
good you're looking you're looking
really good today I wanted to say thanks
I think you are that's awesome
I like your shirt yeah yep so what you
doing here on vacation so you grew up
here in San Diego
yes sir roni where you gonna live in
your whole life well are all the people
in San Diego cool like you nice people
like you everybody's pretty mellow and
laid-back yeah I can't really complain
I really like your shorts man thank you
there are those uh those are
hummingbirds yep that's awesome
awesome you seem like a very adventurous
dude Thanks you have like really
distinct features you know like hmm it's
very unique you know like take different
parts from other people and just fits
well you know any mean thanks I don't
know let's just say I like your hut
thank you and your side appreciate that
now I understand that you are a skater
you you dressed like you are they just
got your feet in a groove you yeah you
think I look like a skater yeah I know
okay good or not uh I don't know I like
to be mysterious uh-huh kind of watch
that it's nice watch yeah I get that a
lot it's a pretty cheap watch but it
looks pretty good everybody asked me
about it but it's the best kind of watch
watches are cheap and cheap and catches
attention I guess yeah so my watch got
lucky on it but just a basic watch Oh
but you have really nice style thank you
- thank you thank you hey man I got to
tell you your beard man I'm trying yeah
yeah you have a very good nice beard
it's pretty pretty good oh thanks thanks
man hey bro I got to say the beard is
working for you thank you so how long
did you take a while to grow it or you
just kind of like short-term I like your
beard
appreciate it and you looking kind of
spiffy today some like wave check all
right one compliment I can't give you
have nice hair so when I get out I'm
excited to grow my hair out so that's
something I'm looking forward to I can't
do that now very dumb out of regulations
now so yeah that's one of us that's a
compliment right nicer I like I like
your shirt I like your glasses
thank you I can see the anytime yeah
thank you yeah I actually just got this
shirt add a like pile sale at a thrift
store in Long Beach visiting San Diego
for work
cool yeah this is my first time in
Balboa Park yeah mine too and you know I
met stranger off the strangest no no
place I like it yeah I'm enjoying it too
what are you doing here uh chili my
girlfriend okay yes is that her over
there cases over there what are you what
you guys it said we went to the beach
Starbucks that seems like you had a nice
day no speech oh you seem very like a
very person yeah yeah I like that man
fear
all right you're sure oh thanks man
appreciate it I just got like the little
wooden uh yeah wooden Carly in school oh
where do you go nice business of mine
it's nice
so you're a smart guy okay so I'm like
that yeah yeah what's your name
Finn Finn I'm Barney yeah that's a cool
name
well thank you I got a one syllable name
you got a one full moon yeah where are
you from Austin San Diego San Diego nice
actually I go to school out here but I'm
not from here how are you used to like
being this hot it's like a thousand
degrees yeah I've never been like I need
a hat like this I really like your hair
Thanks
what is that like a woolly mammoth yeah
mammoth we go snowboarding a lot there
okay yeah yeah this is your dad over
here and your brother yep what's your
dad's name [ __ ]
okay what's your brother's name I you
guys got a cool name
got a one syllable name over here that's
pretty cool I like your tattoos you like
them thank you I appreciate it
do they have any symbolic meanings yeah
yeah that stays for Romans 1:16 that's
really Christian yeah the flowers around
it do with a verse there's a verse in
Isaiah and the Bible talks about when
you pass through the waters I'm with you
so it's kind of like you know when
you're going through hard times in life
God is with you and never leaves you so
yeah yeah yeah yeah I like your chain
Thanks
actually my grandma gave it to me did
she it's kind of weird I like it that's
nice it matches your your bracelet
oh thanks for my grandpa it's got the
same yeah my grandmother and my grandpa
no fair enough fair enough very nice
yeah from England so you can all the way
from England just to cook for Nia to
walk for you no okay
yeah I came over here I came over to
Seattle we flew to and then we went down
to like Portland and basically all the
way down the west coast and our vendored
up here Balboa Park right are you not a
stranger I'm a stranger she already
miked you up to my reveal but everything
it took like to say it but I got my
compliment already worked out for you
about flight perfect you got great style
right she saw like the tattoo he said
they we had to complement each other no
so I guess it's a built on doing like
spreading kindness and so she just said
you know challenges see if you get one
man to compliment another man that
genuinely it's like I said you guys you
got a good stuff I don't like what you
got going on here I love the wolf tattoo
there's still like a very genuinely nice
human being thank you very much yeah we
like are we like oh the whole time we
were no no I thought we were waiting for
a cue all right yeah hold up well I mean
we already win I think we're from OBS my
daughter over there that's Eliza Hale I
don't want to be on camera so I don't
either
I know the feeling we might be famous
though you know who knows if this goes
like viral we get a cut right yeah we
get all the all the comments below who
are these guys yeah like who are these
losers alright well so uh nice to meet
you yeah you're you're an awesome dude
all right yeah you have a good vibe yeah
like you too yeah that's the kind of
person it helps yeah
all right thank you guys again for
watching another episode and I hope you
enjoyed the new project if you did
please hit the like button and leave me
a comment because that's the only way
I'll know that you want it to be a
regular series on my channel other than
that I made a new shirt it says hey
stranger and if you want to check it out
I'll have it linked in my description
that's pretty much it I'll see you guys
next week
you